[Music]
hey guys it's jna here it's bright and
early in the morning the best time to
get your workout done so today's workout
is a series of really effective core
exercises inspired by ballerinas and
also yoga practitioners to get a rock
Sun core when you think about your core
it isn't just about the apps in fact it
involves your lower and midback as well
as your pelvic and hip muscles it is
basically the entire midsection that
holds your spine and your entire body
together so if you do this workout
consistently you will not only gain a
tighter midsection but you will increase
in your Fitness performance as well as
gain a better balance and posture this
workout is low impact and very gentle on
the knees so it is great for any one of
you with bad knees or even lower back
pain because it will help to relieve the
pain and strengthen your lower back so
let's wake our muscles up so the first
workout will be plank to chair so I just
want you to stand at the end of your
yoga mat and get down into a plank
position
okay make sure you have a stable Plank
and then bring your right leg in right
beside your hand your left leg in and we
just want to slowly rise up okay and
sink back down into a slight chair
position so not a full squat just
slightly okay and just hold there for
five counts keep your body upright your
chest open and just keep your hands by
your ears good and now bring your palms
down touch bring your left leg back your
right leg back and back into a plank and
just hold there for another five counts
five 4 4 3 2 1 and now let's repeat so
right leg forward wide step left leg
just bring your body up straight and
just sink into a slight chair open your
chest push your butt back and just
really lengthen your spine and look
forward okay lengthen your spine open up
your chest and just hold it for five 4 3
2 1 good back down touch left leg back
right leg back and hold solid plank make
sure your hands and your shoulders are
in line okay tighten your core engage
your core do not deep or Arch good just
hold it here 5 4 3 2 one let's go again
right leg forward wi step left leg
forward step bring your entire body up
straight lengthen and sit into a chair
good look straight ahead look up if you
want to Hands by your ears and just hold
it feel your hips feel your pelvic bones
open feel your thigh muscles and just
hold it 5 4 3 2 1 good let's go for two
more so now right leg back left leg back
hold into a
plank breathe look straight down at one
point and just hold it
breathe 5 4 3 2 one and now wi step left
leg forward right beside your palm right
leg same thing raise up lengthen your
spine and dip good open your chest make
sure that your toes and your knees do
not go over okay if you want to you can
sit slightly higher up good five 4 3 2
one and one last time right leg back
left leg back hold into a plank just
hold it
here
breathe and Brace your core tighten your
core look
down if you're shaking that is at
absolutely fine 3 2 one now bring your
left leg forward wide step right leg
adjust lift your body up lengthen your
spine and just dip and one last set just
hold it here okay really lengthen your
spine and feel your back muscles being
stretched out feel your legs working
feel your chest opening up feel your
pelvic bone and your hip opening up and
drop down and left leg back right leg
back and just hold it for another eight
counts okay solid plank eight 7 6 5 4 3
2 one good job knees down and now just
stretch it out slightly very good
all right and now let's stand up we want
to get into standing mermaid okay so
feet together okay we want to start on
our left side so just stretch your right
arm across okay and then slowly lift and
crunch to the side simple as that so
let's go for 10 reps and really lengthen
it is all about lengthening and
stretching ready let's go stretch to the
side lengthen and and crunch good this
will require some balance and crunch
graceful good feet together and crunch
nice let's go lengthen point
four length and
point five nice and
graceful five more halfway there six woo
point seven crunch feel the side of it
ABS working eight crunch good balance on
your left leg
nine and one more 10 now same thing on
the other side okay so balance on your
right leg stretch to your left really
lengthen and crunch good feet together
lengthen and crunch nice
together crunch
balance together and crunch good so
really engage these muscles gain your
balance and feel the stretch and also
crunch let's go for four more
one two do this part as well
three and four very nice so now let's
get done on tall mat we want to do some
plank work on the mat with a little bit
of variation so the third workout is
going to be all falls floating cake so
get down onto the mat get into all falls
okay let's start on our left leg okay so
I just want you to tuck your toes under
lift your body up slightly just hover
just about 2 Ines of the floor left leg
straight kick back squeeze your butt
bring it in crunch your abs and bring it
back okay that's it so slow and control
and let's go for 10 if you're shaking
that is absolutely fine three
kick crunch in four good kick back
squeeze your butt five don't rush the
workout it is all about engaging the
right muscles six kick
back seven woo can you feel your muscles
shaking eight
kick good nine kick one more in and and
10 kick good now just drop relax for a
little while and we want to do the same
thing on our right leg okay so tuck your
toes under bring your body up and now
let's go for the right side bring it in
Kick good squeeze your butt in crunch
two in three
good you will also work on your
shoulders and your arms four n nice kick
woo five kick the slight movement is
going to make your core burn six nice in
seven make sure you're in a nice solid
plank
eight nine one more and 10 and now just
drop down on all fs and get into a child
pose and just relax for a little while
give
good all
right now back up we want to add a
little bit more variation so what we
want to do is go for plank to downwards
Dog Okay so let's start again Plank and
let's start on our left leg so what I
want you to do is bring your left leg in
and kick it up and feel a deep stretch
on your back and your entire body bring
it back in to a plank and kick it out
good good so look straight down
in and out stretch stretch okay really
feel the stretch on your back kick as
high as you can pointed legs four nice
in five good feel the stretch on your
butt as well six
engage every
muscles seven
in woo wake your body up guys three more
eight
stretch
nine
stretch last one on the left side in and
stretch good job now just down on all
fours and child pose just to relax if at
any time you feel that you need to relax
just get into a child pose okay okay
make sure you're breathing Pace your
breathing nice now let's get up again
same thing now let's go on our right
side I am dripping right nice solid
plank okay let's go right leg in Kick
all the way up make sure you're
stretching feel your back muscles in
really Point as high as you can and get
your core stretch those back three
good can you see a sweat dripping I
can
four
stretch
nice five what a great way to use those
muscles and to get your body engaged and
working together six
kick in 7
[Music]
point eight
relax it's all about the breathing Pace
your breathing two more n Pace your
breathing last one 10 and kick it up and
just hold it there stretch feel your
legs working stay in a balanced Plank
and just bring it in again go into a
child
pose very
good so how are you guys doing so far we
have one final exercise okay it's going
to be AB full okay so for this one I
want you to lie down on your chest it's
going to be a little bit like
Superman except we won't be using the
upper body or working on the upper body
so just place your hands in front of you
place your um forehead on your hand and
I want you to spread your legs slightly
apart okay lift them up and only want to
do is squeeze them together okay so
you're using your lower back to lift
your legs up and you're using your inner
thighs and outer thighs and your butt to
bring them together good let's go for 15
all right four relax your upper body
five hold it
high
six good
spread seven
nice eight keep
going woo breathe nine
up 10 last five
up
one remember to breathe through your
nose out through your nose
two up
three up four one last one guys up and
squeeze them
together and just relax
let's get into a child pose okay well
done guys very well
done and just breathe and feel your
breath settling into your
body and just
relax relax your mind feel your muscles
being stretched out so get yourself
hydrated and take a one minute break
some of you might already know I've been
working with the National Academy of
sports medicine and ASM to get you guys
who are passionate about helping people
to lead a healthier and more Balanced
Life to take up and sign up to their
online personal training cost I believe
that if you're passionate to help others
to live and you know be healthier it is
important to get the foundation of your
education they are currently offering a
14-day free trial to their online
personal training C you will learn more
about Fitness Nutrition writing a
personalized fitness program
understanding your clients and waste on
becoming a successful trainer so do
click on the link in my description box
for more information let's get back onto
the mat and do the second set right so
let's start with the first workout plank
to chair okay so get down into a plank
position okay solid plank let's hold it
for five counts right five four 3 2 1
now let's bring your left leg forward
while step right leg all right bring
your body up lengthen your spine and
let's dip into a slight chair okay
embrace your core lengthen your back
Hands by your ears nice and feel your
pelvic bone opening up and your thighs
working hold it five 4 3 2 one hands
down left leg back right leg back back
and now again a solid plank okay if
someone were to sit on your back you
should be able to hold this plank good
solid engage really suck your tummy in
and hold it for five 4 3 2 one very good
again let's repeat left leg right step
forward right leg stand up lengthen
yourself and dip into a chair good okay
only as low as you can without leaning
too far forward we don't want this all
right so up straight push your butt back
don't over atch your back and just count
with me five 4 three feel your back two
one down left leg back right leg back
and hold eight counts for this plank
eight 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 and let's repeat
left leg forward wi step right leg by
your palms raise up lengthen your spine
stretch your back and now let's dip good
just a slight dip is enough really
lengthen and engage the midback muscle
okay feel the stretch feel like someone
is pulling you up five
4 3 2 one Palms down left leg back right
leg back and hold into a plank good job
engage those core shoulders and make
sure you're breathing throughout the
workout if you're shaking that is fine
five 4 and three 2 one now let's bring
our right side forward wi step left good
lengthen up straight make sure you're
Long Tall and long and then dip good all
right spread your toes keep your balance
engage
andage very nice breathe through your
nose out through your
nose and now one more set Palms down
left leg back right leg back
and just hold the plank one last time
okay hold
it the more you do this workout you will
only be more flexible you only feel more
alive within yourself and your muscles
and you will start to feel the right
body part working 5 4 3 2 one and now
right leg wi stab very nice wide stab
lengthen stretch and one last
dip okay so no forward no leaning
forward just nice and sit
tall very nice very graceful and very
tall 5 4 3 2 1 and let's just drop and
get back into one last plank
okay and hold
it 8 7 6 5
4 3 2 one and now just drop your knees
and get into a chow
pose
relax relax shake it out a little bit
and just
relax right now let's stand up okay
standing mermaid again feet together
good left arm by your side and let's
stretch to our right side all right
ready long again it's all about
lengthening the spine and then crunch
good look at one point to find a balance
good crunch slow
movement 10 on each side three very good
take the time to elongate
four
elongate five good feel the side being
stretched cred and then being crushed
six crunch seven good look the opposite
side eight feet together feel the sun on
your face
nine oh I love the morning sun 10 good
feet together the other side okay so
same thing elongate Stand Tall stretch
and crunch good job job
stretch and crunch very
nice oh good
three I love to stretch my muscles four
who
doesn't keep going five make sure you're
standing tall no hunching really tighten
this midsection six tighten this okay if
you want to really suck it in suck your
butt in as well seven
elongate
eight last two nine just like a mermaid
and 10 well done let's get down onto the
mat all right so now on all
fours let's start with our left leg okay
so make sure you have a good and steady
balance and then tuck your toes in lift
your body up and now let's go with our
left side crunch in extend kick and feel
about working kick okay to hold this
position you really have to engage your
core good
slow don't rush the
workout feel your muscles shaking that
is absolutely normal in fact it is
really good because it means you're
engaging your muscles six
in seven good in
8 good kick
nine small kick last one 10
good and now just drop and just relax
for a little while roll your shoulder if
you want to and we want to be working on
our right side okay so are you ready Tu
Your Toes in Hover a little bit just two
inches off the floor right leg
kick very nice you know squeeze those
butt good bring them in feel one side of
your abs working
crunch kick three good
four nice nice and
control
five 6 when it gets tough guys remember
to hold it and breathe
seven eight you are strong last two more
nine last one 10 oh my God woo and let's
just get into a help us and just rest
here for a little while stretch it
out breathe lengthen your
spine and just relax for a little while
okay before we move on to the next
workout take a deep breath in and
out right still onto the plank let's add
a little bit more variation okay plank
to downward dog right start on our left
leg this is actually my favorite because
you can really feel the stretch so left
leg in kick all the way up lengthen
Point stretch all the way
in and stretch good job Point elbows to
knees
three woo you know feel your upper back
your mid back your lower back opening up
and really feel the Deep stretch all the
way into your spine
4 five b balance good six as high as
Point as you can
nice in
seven woo last three more eight squeeze
your butt right at the top keep it
balance two more
nine look at your sweat it is good last
one in and stretch and just hold it
there 5 4 3 2 1 and now just drop into a
chers relax a little while and we want
to work on the other side
okay catch your breath and now let's go
one last one on the right side let's go
crunch in lengthen lengthen lengthen
stretch it out
point in remember just like a ballerina
Point those toes
two in if you want to look
down
okay last
four
point
good
in five halfway there it's all about
flow okay we want to get into a nice
flow to work the
muscles and the core four more guys keep
going you should be awake by now if
you're sleepy last
three stretch stretch stretch last two
point those butt
[Music]
up and one
more
in and
point and hold it there 5 4 3 2 two one
just drop your leg and drop your knees
knees into downward
dog all
right very well done one final workout
I'm absolutely stretching I'm loving it
and I'm feeling really fresh so done
onto your belly remember hands
forward forehead on your hand and just
engage your little back bring it up and
squeeze it in okay engage your your L
back to keep your body up your butt up
your hips off the floor throughout the
whole time three point your
toes four very
graceful
squeeze five feel your outer and inner
thighs open your pelvic bone six open
your hips seven good job guys keep going
open
eight open
nine slow and controlled 10 five more
let's go bring it up
one
two last three
three four oh my God woo we're almost at
last one guys come on hold it hold it
and
squeeze well done okay a very well
deserved workout so now let's get into a
child pose
again and just relax everything because
you've done such a good
job okay bring your mind come your body
down come your breath down and just
breathe so guys I hope you enjoyed the
workout this is a low impact workout yet
I am still drenched in sweat I can feel
the sun shining right in my face and I
know that I can start my day feeling
really good personally I like to balance
up between my low impact and high impact
workout just to you know keep the good
balance so if you enjoy this workout for
best result do this workout two to three
times weekly to really strengthen the
core get a Slimmer waistline and it is
also a really good total body workout if
you enjoy this workout be sure to like
it and share it with your friends as
well all the
[Music]
best